what's your recommendation for an an
employee that is late to work who
usually is late but they're usually a
good performer so being late is
unacceptable
and III tell us whenever I work with a
company and they start talking about we
know this guy's late for a meeting
sometimes I was home that I was in the
military for 20 years and I was
literally never late
I was literally never late one time yeah
think about that 20 years never late
never late never late any time for
anything we would you know we would show
up at work in the morning so early that
even if the worst case scenario my I got
t-boned on the way to work I would still
be able to get insurance get everything
covered get a cab and so show up and be
an hour early so you should be you're
right in the fact that being on time is
definitely very very important so people
shouldn't be late so now with this
individual you got someone that's
showing up late for work you've got it
like any other leadership challenge what
I would attack is making sure they
understand why why is it important some
people never make the connection as to
why being on time is important so you've
got to explain to them why it's
important you got to explain to them
that's basic respect for other people's
time that it's basic operational
readiness is to follow a timeline that
it's about being prepared that it's
about showing your reliability and your
professionalism
to other people that you're working with
inside and outside of your company and
even sunsoo
Sun Tzu and I I didn't say this during
the during the podcast that we did about
Sun Tzu and I can't believe I didn't say
it because I always believed in look
waking up early and being early and Sun
Tzu said that he who is waiting on the
battlefield is gonna win and who he was
rushing late to the battlefield is gonna
lose well that's the way your life is -
and if you're Russian and you things are
disorganized and you're running late
it's horrible but if you wake up early
and you show up early and you're ready
and you're prepared and you're waiting
on the battlefield you're gonna win
that's all there is to it so those the
important things that you have to
explain to your employee that they so
that they understand why being late
isn't unacceptable and why being on time
is this standard that needs to be
maintained some people it's a horrible
habit that some people have of being
late it's a horrible habit yeah you
don't want to get into it it just just
unreliability yeah I was one of those
people he's working the night club in
here San Diego downtown for a while -
from like 7 years and unlike you I feel
like I feel like I don't know I don't
engage it or another of count'em but it
feels like I was late at the very least
one minute late you know you have a
shift right you know starts at whatever
time either one minute late or ten
minutes late I feel like I was more late
more times than I was on time like right
so my dad was always late I come from a
long line of late guys nonetheless but I
was this guy I was the guy was a good
performer I felt like I mean according
to my bosses and stuff and I would you
know I'd do well it other than the time
thing I was pretty reliable very
reliable in the nightclub industry so
and I'd always justify it like man all
this time I would you know take to be
prepared to get there and find parking
and all this stuff I could be doing
something else in my life or whatever
not necessarily useful stuff but just
something
what do I have to work while I'm not
working you know like preparing for work
I don't know that was kind of my
attitude as long as I have good output
as long as my job is being done it's
fine
so when I stop the you know when I was
done with a nightclub or um industry
Jade my brother would um he explained it
to me where and the the the thing that I
read that really kind of hit me was
being late is a blatant disregard and a
blatant display of disrespect to the
person or people who are waiting for you
no doubt in their time which is time is
like when you really think about it's
the most valuable thing you have so even
if you're talking about one minute
are you talking about one hour you are
wasting that person's time if you have a
meeting or something right you can you
show up five minutes late people are
waiting for you to start the meeting
that's five minutes gone where you know
we still have to go over that material
so we're gonna spend an extra five
minutes just because you're relate
because you fail to prepare everyone
else was there on time and you're the
one doing it you know so and then also I
learned through a I want to say it was a
book I read I forget where but where one
of the two major thing main things that
ensure your success or will get in the
way of your success is reliability being
reliable so and and one day I went to
the store right and my wife sends me in
the shopping spree she says get this
kind of tomatoes like canned tomatoes
but it was like a this specific kind you
ever try to go chuffer can't tomatoes
brother there's like this one and this
one this one I'm like I'm just gonna eat
it just grab one anyone cuz I can't find
this one or I'm not gonna get them at
all I'm just gonna go home and be like
you get two Tomatoes if you I don't even
want whatever it is you're making with
shit so imma but I'm getting frustrated
on the inside like like look down the
line of frustrating things that I've
told myself all the way to the point of
this isn't my job to do this it is my
job by the way but this isn't my job I
don't want Tomatoes why should i why am
I even shopping right now why is like
this story
I'm making a point and it might be an is
a very important point so if I do that
if I'm like you know it's
I'm not getting the tomatoes so I'm just
gonna go ahead and settle for the wrong
one
I've demonstrated and basically
proclaimed that I am unreliable so why
would anyone come to me for anything
who's to say I'm gonna be reliable about
it and sure you might be reliable on
some things but you've demonstrated that
you can and will be unreliable under
certain circumstances and those
circumstances are dictated by by you so
who knows really you're not gonna get
hired no you're not you might not even
be if somebody's friend what do you
think well it it or husband or whatever
you know yeah definitely it shows lack
of being on time shows a total
disrespect for other people's time and
it shows a lack of reliability on your
part so these are the kind of things you
got to explain to your subordinates or
explain to this person that's being
constantly late so that they understand
why you're telling them that and then
you they can then they can improve and
then you can that you know if the person
is a good performer generally that means
their type of person I care about how
they're perceived and doing a good job
so let's get them to understand how
being late affects everybody else and
affects their own reputation as as a
performer yeah so it'll mean something
to him plus you'll be it come through
guy everyone likes to come through a guy
who comes through I'm sure they liked
you for coming in on time every single
day for 20 years yeah they did